und in berlin begrüße ich den
bundesvorsitzenden des deutschen
hausärzteverbandes ulrich weigeldt hallo
in die hauptstadt
und morgen erwartet sie haben diese
woche ja von freibier stimmung in der
debatte um booster impfungen und
impfzentren gesprochen was ist denn so
schlecht an freibier in bayern ist doch
seit langem ein bewährtes rezept
weiß ich gar nicht ob das so günstig ist
und freibier ausgeschenkt ist es für die
gesundheit auch sicherlich nicht
zuträglich
ich glaube man darf solche dinge nicht
aus dem zusammenhang reißen
unser hauptproblem ist nach wie vor dass
wir einen großteil der bevölkerung haben
die nicht geimpft ist und dann nutzen
uns auch keine hilfe zentren oder sonst
irgendwas dort gibt nur jemand hinter
weiß dass er geimpft werden will und das
ist nicht unser problem da hängt aber
die frage ob manche impfzentren wieder
aufgemacht werden soll darum geht ja die
debatte nicht zuletzt davon ab wer diese
tritt impfungen dieser
auffrischungsimpfungen bekommen soll
angenommen die stiko erweitert ihre
empfehlungen sind denn die
niedergelassenen ärzte die sie vertreten
wirklich allein in der lage das zu
leisten
also ich glaube dass sie in der lage
sind das zu leisten aber ich glaube auch
dass man den fokus hier verschoben hat
aus welchen gründen auch immer und ich
bin froh dass gestern wieder bekannt
wurde dass man sich tatsächlich darauf
konzentriert was machen wir mit den
menschen die nicht geimpft sind die
nicht geimpft sind und im alten und
pflegeheim arbeiten die nicht geimpft
sind in der schule sind wir haben das
jetzt gesehen da gibt es ausnahmen da
kann man dann damit umgehen aber es
dauert problem sind erwachsene
ungeimpfte und da nützt es nichts wenn
ich jetzt über booster impfung
diskutiere bin ich sehr betagte menschen
habe deren immunsystem gar nicht mehr so
einwandfrei funktioniert dann nutzt
wahrscheinlich auch die sechzehnte
booster impfung nichts wenn sie von
einem infizierten erwachsenen umgerüstet
werden kommen wir doch mal auf diese zu
geringe impfbereitschaft zu sprechen
zwei drittel der deutschen sind bisher
durch geben das ist aber zu wenig um
eben eine pandemie der ungeimpften die
ja schon grassiert zu verhindern was
wäre denn der vorschlag um die fehlenden
30 doch noch zur impfung zu bewegen
zunächst einmal wäre mein vorschlag sich
darauf zu konzentrieren anstatt über
booster impfung für jugendliche
erwachsene nachzudenken und das zweite
ist es ist auch ein teil verschlafen
worden wir haben vorschläge gemacht und
es wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht anders
gehen als tatsächlich hier auf die
menschen zuzugehen gegebenenfalls auch
vorteile hin zu gewähren wir haben oft
von der berühmten bratwurst gesprochen
da gibt es sicher auch andere wege und
da ist es richtig den fokus darauf zu
nehmen die kanzlerin hat das gestern der
markt findet das völlig in ordnung und
man muss auch sagen wer als erwachsener
ungeimpft ohne dass er den schaden hatte
er das impfen verhindert eine krankheit
in der gegend rum läuft aber dann
natürlich das solidarsystem in anspruch
nimmt wenn er krank wird also das sind
diskrepanzen über die muss man
vielleicht offensiver diskutieren aber
was können denn konkret die hausärzte
selbst dazu beitragen ihre patienten
zumindest die ungeimpften doch wieder zu
einer impfung zu bewegen es gab ja mal
70.000 politik gegen corinna geimpft
haben die zahl ist dramatisch und liegt
jetzt wohl wieder etwa 30.000 praxen
also können da nicht auch den
niedergelassenen ärzte einen größeren
beitrag leisten als es im moment tun
ja machen wir gerne haben wir auch getan
wir haben auch zu zeiten unseren beitrag
geleistet als wir unsere schutzkleidung
selber nähen mussten und sehen uns jetzt
sehr lauter vorwürfen ausgesetzt wir
müssen vielleicht die rahmenbedingungen
ansehen ja weil sie sich angucken das in
der praxis der ganze aufwand der info
mit 20 euro vergütet wird worüber wer
nicht geklagt haben aber da muss man
irgendwann darüber reden während das
impfzentrum das zehnfache verschlingt da
muss man einfach mal die dinge
geraderücken und wir natürlich wir haben
ja viele patienten überzeugt weil die
kommen ja nicht zu uns weil sie geimpft
werden wollen unbedingt
die anderen krankheiten sind bekanntlich
nicht ausgestorben und deswegen kommen
sie mit anderen erkrankungen und geben
uns gelegenheit zu sagen passen sie mal
auf sind noch nicht geimpft und viele
sind ja gar nicht bewusste impfgegner
können wir uns da nicht mehr auf einen
termin einigen oder wir machen das
gleich zusammen mit der grippeimpfung da
kriegen wir schon viele menschen die zu
uns in die praxen kommen überzeugt dass
sie sich doch dann impfen lassen selbst
nach den aktuellen empfehlungen der
stiko jedenfalls rechnet man mit etwa 15
millionen menschen die in den nächsten
wochen und monaten eine auffrischung
bekommen das wäre ja noch mehr
tatsächlich wenn es auch gelänge die
ungeimpften zu überzeugen wie sieht es
dann auch mit der bestellung von
impfstoff da wird wieder eine menge
gebraucht werden in den nächsten monaten
läuft das bürokratische prozedere läuft
das bestellverfahren zu ihrer
zufriedenheit
na ja das muss man sagen ist regional
unterschiedlich wir haben natürlich
klagen dass es zu lange dauert bis der
impfstoff tatsächlich in die praxis
kommt das ist aber nicht überall so wir
glaube ich können da mehr schaffen wenn
wir den impfstoff schneller bekommen wir
wissen dass die firmen daran arbeiten
uns das prozedere in der praxis zu
erleichtern denn man darf nicht nur
sehen dass dieses aufziehen auch
gefahren vorbereiten der spritzen
relativ aufwändig ist gegenüber anderen
empfohlen und insofern glaube ich dass
wir hier regional gucken müssen wo es
noch hakt dass dort die belieferung der
praxen auch schneller erfolgt und
offenbar liegt ja der vorlauf sozusagen
bei teilweise noch zwei bis drei wochen
müsste sich auch das tatsächlich ändern
dass man sozusagen zeitnäher den bedarf
anmelden kann
absolut es ist ja bei allen anderen
medikamenten bei impfungen bei solchen
dingen völlig unüblich solche lange
vorlaufzeit zu haben und daher laut
gesundheitsminister in ausreichend
impfstoff übrig sind teilweise daher
sogar in den lagern verfällt muss man
halt war hier an der logistik noch ein
bisschen arbeiten oder ähnlich arbeiten
damit wie bei anderen impfstoffen ist
auch von einem tag auf den andern oder
anderen wegen nach spätestens drei
werktage den impfstoff zur verfügung
habe es ist deswegen auch wichtig dass
sie ihre frage auch völlig berechtigt
wenn jemand sich dann überzeugen die es
sich impfen zu lassen dann muss ich das
auch sofort machen da kann ich nicht
sagen kommen sie bitte mal in drei
wochen dann ist vielleicht dieser
impetus dann schon wieder verflogen also
insofern ist das auch ein wichtiges
moment und letzte frage mit der bitte
eine kurze antwort was erwarten sie sich
von einer neuen bund länder hunde wenn
sie denn tatsächlich nächste woche
zustande kommt welchen kurs für den
winter würden sie sich wünschen
also ich verweise nur auf die ergebnisse
der letzten bund länder runden also ist
wir haben ein föderales system
wir werden unterschiedliche strategien
haben das ist auch nicht nur schlecht
weil sich dann vielleicht best practice
ergibt und ich glaube dass wir aus dem
tunnelblick wonach ein bisschen raus
kommen müssen weil wir haben sehr viele
andere infektionen mit ihr einfachen
viren die gerade die kinder und
jugendlichen betreffen und deswegen
glaube ich müssen die kontakte haben um
ihr immunsystem trend zu trainieren und
nicht auf dem hinweis auf irgendwelche
lankowitz fantasien jetzt weiter
eingesperrt werden heraus kommen aus dem
corona tunnelblick sagt der
bundesvorsitzende des deutschen
hausärzteverbandes ulrich weigeldt ich
danke ihnen für das gespräch und schöner
größer einen schönen tag nach berlin
dankeschön wiedersehen